good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday happy
hump day happy second day on the new
interface hey claude how are you doing
hello jacqueline i am doing great it is
hump day i am i've already humped
someone i love so i'm just i don't know
i'm kicking off the day in a really
positive headspace we absolutely love to
hear that and also we are so excited
because we are recording today's episode
still remote but there is a video
component so if you have been waiting
for the youtube to come back head over
there if you're listening as a podcast
and for the youtube listeners we're
sorry we've missed you too and now you
can see like brew in the background with
heating pad you can really you can see
these beautiful faces even though mine
the pimples the pores the puff the bloat
the puff the bloat
that's
very real to me today i didn't have time
to gua sha or um i swirl my face so
you're just getting the full pizza face
today
i am beyond ice rolling you know this is
just who i am now no that's an important
thing like i feel like for a long time i
was like washing every morning like and
i definitely saw some some lifting some
sculpting but at the end of the day this
is who i am this is my face it is round
and i must learn to love the things i
cannot change or i will not change
yeah i i agree but still you know
sometimes it's nice to feel like you're
doing something
for thyself productive well we're doing
something productive because we have a
fabulous show you know yesterday's
episode was
low-key like a banger it was so funny i
actually went back and listened to it as
a podcast which i don't really do
sometimes i'll go back and watch youtube
but bobble we were just we were killing
it
i mean justice for bobble because he's
getting cheated on left and right
yesterday's episode was really funny and
i'm really excited for today's we have a
lot to talk about we have to recap
vanderpump rules i had such a busy day
yesterday finishing up the book for the
redheads and then we recorded the
episode of the redheads last night so
that will be up tomorrow for the
community and i also think like january
is a great month for the redheads
community in general a lot of people
resolute to read more and they want to
jump in with a snitch's choice so the
episode was really funny it was actually
way more polarizing than i thought it
was gonna be i thought we were all just
gonna be like yay cute snitch's choice
but there was dissension
scandal amongst the redheads scandal it
hasn't been that heated since clara in
the sun honestly
oh a dark time for the community if you
know you know so that'll be up tomorrow
and it's always a good time recording
with the girls i finished um
emily in paris so just for me remind me
to touch on that in the tv recap segment
because i have thoughts and they are
overwhelmingly negative which is tough
for me because you know i'm starting out
this year on like a positive foot i'm
getting my hair cut today new year new
me and emily is just bringing like that
negativity that heaviness that darkness
that i was consumed by in 2021 um it's
bringing it straight into 2022. it's
hard to be positive while also being
factual
and it's hard to be positive when you're
watching emily paris period yeah no like
except there's like something about
positivity that requires a bit of
delusion
jackie
i couldn't have phrased the sentence any
more perfectly
okay then we'll leave it at that and
that's just something for you guys to
chew on
not even
delusion borderline like ignorance
willfully ignoring like what's going on
like look around why would you be
positive
right
okay cool i'm glad that you know we have
something to think about today i feel
like we're asking in the new year like
in these three episodes we're really
asking some big questions like
what's in a name you know what is in a
name a lot there's a lot in a name
so true
so how was your night otherwise without
emily ruining it it was good oh my god
you know like ben
like has an obsession with these breathe
right strips
no but okay okay so like a couple months
ago he started snoring really bad and it
was waking me up like at all parts of
the night so i'm like you have to do
something about it so we went to dwayne
reed and he bought these strips that he
puts on his nose he wears them around
the house like at noon like it's not
even just for sleeping he loves them
there's nothing statement they're a
fashion statement he got a pr package
from the brand and like for him like
that's like you getting a birkin like he
hit
peak
peak influencing and i guess like last
night was the first night in a really
long time that he forgot to put one on
before bed i was up all night like
shoving him turning him to his side so
i'm like [ __ ] cranky this morning and
i like yelled like i know snoring is out
of people's control like i'm
how how can you be mad at someone for
like a bodily function but i found a way
and i was so like i'm like a little
cranky like if you're feeling if you're
sensing that blame ben
okay i will definitely blame ben and
even though snoring you know
i guess technically is not
a person's fault it feels like it is and
it also feels like an internal attack
and they do say like if you sleep on
your side you won't snore so i mean per
like right now i have to sleep on my
side and like of course i would love to
sleep on my back but i'm like nope sleep
on your side ben doesn't it it's clear
that he's not you know pushing himself
to sleep on his side as well
i think there's something borderline
sociopathic about sleeping on your back
like it's insane really
side and belly
okay yeah i miss sleeping on my belly so
much especially when you've got a
heating pad under there so good so good
but sleep i i mean i have to sleep on my
side now and i feel like after i'm
pregnant i'm never gonna do it again
it's like really annoying to have to do
all the time yeah belly is like my
number one choice but i think there's
just something really creepy about
people who's like number one goat way of
sleeping is on their back and i think
it's mostly men and i think it's really
[ __ ] crazy okay i it's not my number
one preferred method of sleeping but i
do enjoy it it's like probably top four
positions
well there are only four people so you
see those like charts that are like yes
all the different ways that you could
sleep and i think my favorite way to
sleep is like on my side but like on my
belly too
you know yeah which i can't do which i
can't do right now either but i do like
a back moment sometimes no for me like
the number one way is belly right leg up
like bent knee hands under the pillow
damn you know what i've noticed recently
i sleep with so much tension like i grip
my pillows so much and obviously like my
jaw is always like clenched shut and i
need i've been trying to consciously
like
relax but i literally don't know how to
relax and like my shoulders in general
are always at my ears what yeah
no and i'll be like trying to fall
asleep and i'm like i wonder why i can't
fall asleep maybe it's like then you
realize how much tension you're
clenching in your jaw
like i'm like oh my god i can't even
have any teeth left
yeah yeah no that's something i'm trying
to be more mindful of in the new year
we are like turning this into like a
wellness podcast we're gonna have to
switch categories soon at the rate we're
going
literally well it's fine because comedy
is so cut throat i would love to be
number one in a different category
rather than number eight in comedy no we
are in such a competitive podcast chart
category and do you know that we
actually we usually peek at about eight
or seven yesterday we made it to six the
episode made it to six yeah
but that's also because it was podcast
only
yes and it was like our first episode
back it was one for monday so but i do
wonder if the youtube listeners are just
boycotting or if they're moving to the
podcast
do let us know do let us know let us
know in the comments on today's youtube
episode because if everything goes
according to plan there should be a
youtube episode
put on makeup for the first time since
new year's ay
yeah i put on makeup i'm looking cute
and i'm like ready i'm ready to change
lives today with this episode okay let's
do our best i don't know if the stories
aren't necessarily life-changing but you
know they are the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
jersey shore family vacation are you
ready to fist pump into the new year i
am tomorrow the jersey shore family is
back on mtv with an all new season of
jersey shore family vacation the
situations are learning what it means to
be new parents but their little one
isn't the only meatball serving up
surprises because snooki is back for
good queen the new year is bringing lots
of new beginnings and some relationships
are being put to the test when fist pump
comes to shove
will pauly d and nikki take things to
the next level can angelina and chris
finally make their marriage work one
thing's for sure the season is going to
be unforgettable so don't miss the new
season of jersey shore family vacation
it all starts tomorrow at 8 7 central on
m
v
exciting thank you for that we're always
looking for new things to watch and
knowing that jersey shore is back is
very exciting
and today's episode is also brought to
you by honey because we all shop online
and we've seen that promo code feel
taunt us at checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
browser extension that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best ones it finds to your cart they
support over 30 000 stores online so
i've used it for food
electronics of course makeup clothing
they really cover i've never been
disappointed by honey so how it works is
once you download the browser extension
for free when you check out a website
the honey button drops down and all you
have to do is click apply coupons and in
a few seconds they will scour the
internet for all the coupons and apply
the best one and you basically just sit
there and watch the price drop
so um again i've used it on food makeup
clothes really everything i've ever
needed when shopping online which is the
way i exclusively shop so there's no
reason not to get honey with our link
you get it for free and then you're just
saving money so if you don't already
have honey you are straight up missing
out on free savings it is free and
installs in a few seconds and by getting
it you'll be doing yourself a solid get
honey for free at joinhoney.com toast
that's join
honey.com
toast
honey is a no-brainer for online
shopping girlies such as ourselves you
literally it's free money with honey and
it makes shopping you know
with a clear conscience you love to see
it
first story some drama kim kardashian
unfollows miley cyrus on instagram after
a pete davidson new year's eve special
so kim has seemingly unfollowed miley on
instagram following the new year's eve
special that we you know gloat about
that we loved with pete davidson a miley
cyrus fan account noted that kardashian
was following the wrecking ball artist's
instagram account on december 10th the
same day page six reported that miley
went to davidson's condo after their
tonight show appearance but as of
tuesday the schemes founder was no
longer listed as one of her followers
the move could signal some three-way
drama among kim miley and pete after the
two of them co-hosted a new year's eve
special in miami on friday
so
this is really
juicy yes it's so juicy and this is a
lot to break down unpack it's layered
yeah no but it's also very real like
sometimes you see like unfollow drama
and i'm like this is another burger but
like this is so real and i have to be
honest when i was watching the new
year's special
i was thinking like if i'm kim and this
is my new man's and we everybody knows
that we're together i would have been
like a little miffed at miley she was
kind of laying it on thick
and
when they were doing the press before
jimmy fallon like
that she was kind of like doing that
still so like if i was the new
girlfriend i would be annoyed
yes okay so i would totally agree i
think there's always like unfollowing
drama and it's never verified whether
like you know kim actually followed
miley to begin with but this is totally
fact-based like this is a database
question like it is totally real
and i have heard a few things of like
page six was basically saying
essentially what you said just like the
inappropriate nature of a lot of you
know the comments during press and
during the actual live show jumois had a
blind that was pretty clearly about the
situation basically saying kim found
inappropriate pictures um
including about around miley on pete's
phone i don't really know if that's true
kim doesn't seem like the type of gal
who like goes through her boyfriend's
phone like she's four kids a billion
dollar business like she's busy and
she's like studying for law school so i
don't really know if i believe that i
personally don't believe that
me neither but i don't think it's
i think there's more to it than you know
just miley acting inappropriately
because at the end of the day like you
have to know who you're dating
that's like pete's shtick you know he's
like this single bachelor guy it's miley
schtick
i don't know i think there's more to the
story that we don't know
perhaps and maybe it's something like
tech like maybe like pete came home and
was like oh my god she's like texting me
whatever right right i don't know but
just based on what we do know i could
see how this led towards like
there's drama and i'm showing her and
like this is not how
you act around someone else's man
yeah no and to be honest like i'm a
little annoyed because i just feel like
i don't know i don't really want kim
like involved in this like she's a
little bit better than like stupid
scandals like this
i i don't think it's a scandal like she
was this girl's like
feel she feels like she's coming onto
her man when everybody knows that
they're dating and i don't want to
follow you anymore i don't want to see
your face on my feed i feel that by the
way there also could be something to you
know kim followed miley for this special
like because she was working with her
man and now the special's over and kim
just didn't feel the need to keep
following her that's also an option how
many people does kim follow currently
i think around 150 but let me check oh
that's hearty that's a hearty amount so
yeah it's not like 10 yeah it's not like
10 and i'm only following the most
relevant people week to week
right right now she's following exactly
150. okay yeah so this is very real and
miley pissed off kim yeah and we just
need to get down to the bottom of like
what was the thing that pissed kim off
because i feel like it takes a lot to
piss kim off she's very tough i agree
and i don't think it was only just like
jimmy fallon and the new year special
because that's sort of
speculative
yeah that's part of the job there was
definitely other stuff but i'm just
saying like even just seeing that stuff
if that was my man i would be annoyed
with this girl
yeah i definitely think the weirdest
thing miley did during the the press was
that cover like it should have been me
yeah that's what this page six article
references that she like serenaded him
on the tonight show saying it should
have been me and also like if kim if
pete wasn't dating kim right now and
these two were doing press and hosting
new year's eve together i would be like
oh my god they need to date there would
be a lot of speculation as to whether
they hooked up are they dating like
because they actually now that i think
about it like are very well matched in
just their vibes right so
everything to me here just like adds up
in terms of why this would
annoy someone's girlfriend you know it's
a recipe for disaster but kim and pete
are going strong they're going to the
bahamas together and i look forward you
know to hopefully
some some photos and some kind of
something like a picture an instagram
story like anything but even just
knowing that they're going on vacation
together it's like another step towards
the biggest ship you've ever seen
it's another step towards step dad pete
davidson oh that's kind of scary
frightening
okay well our next story is related
kanye west and julia fox see slave play
and hit carbon on their first new york
city date so kanye is out there as well
he and julia fox took in a broadway show
with a group of friends on tuesday
before decamping to carbone for dinner
okay can i see something like hella
controversial okay sure when it comes to
like you know the kim and kanye stuff
when i'm reading a story about you know
kanye you know lusting after kim i'm you
know
bright-eyed bushy-tailed when i'm
reading something about who kim is
dating i'm like oh my god give me more
when i'm reading something about like
who connie is dating and maybe it's
because he doesn't date anyone
interesting like i literally don't care
you know what i feel the exact same way
i almost didn't even pick this as a
story but then i was like i had to look
at myself and be like why wouldn't i
care who kanye is dating when i care so
much about him i care about kim i care
about their future you know everything
else he does elections like it's just
like who is this
agreed who is this and also like when he
was dating irena shake we were
interested yes because she's an
interesting person but when he dates
like you know just
models
yeah maybe like fashion girls who are
low-key
it's not pete davidson
yeah it's just not giving me like
the joie de vivre i usually have for
stories like this
yeah no i felt the same way but i did i
felt the need
to look inward and be like of course i
should care that kanye is seeing someone
because it's part of a larger story a
story in what i'm very invested in right
correct
so here we are continue give me the
details it was the couple's first date
night in new york where oh she's in from
uncut gems she's an actress when she's
based in new york
following a few evenings out in miami an
eyewitness also told page six that wes
managed to stay off his phone for the
entirety of the play unlike in 2018 when
he was busted for texting through the
share show
that's okay like it's so rude but it's a
long time to be off your phone like i
sympathize
are you someone who would be on your
phone in a broadway show
no i'm someone if i'm not enjoying the
show and i feel the need to like really
be on my phone i'll take like a long
walk to the toilet like sit on the
toilet catch up on what's going on and
then go back
if i'm being honest but it's so rude
like
when i see people on their phones in my
show like i actually i was at a comedy
club in chicago and like someone was
fully like making a phone call like a
dentist appointment right in front of me
like that's i i know how rude it is so i
would never like fully
be like blatantly rude on my phone but
you know if i'm not enjoying myself i
will excuse myself i think that's fine i
think that's fine also for celebrities
it's like one everyone's watching you
and two like you're typically in a
really good seat so the actors could
probably see you and that's
most likely gifted those tickets for
free but like if you are
in the balcony perhaps a few rows back
you know you have a little privacy
as a person and you get
a text message you could maybe check it
well actually you'd be surprised like
with
theater lights you actually really can't
see the first few rows in front of you
and the person in like the sixth row is
like the only person you could see and
that might be the person on their phone
interesting
yeah
okay well then just don't be on your
phone when you're going to see a
performance that feels like a rule of
thumb that works yeah
agreed you're most likely not missing
anything
except the performance
except the performance you're missing
nothing on your phone
um anyways they went to car bone after
for dinner and the fun fact about me is
i've never been to carbone
and i'm like kidding i know isn't that
so weird and i really want to go and i'm
just literally going tonight
really yeah oh my god will you bring me
back some of that pasta that everyone
takes a picture of drop it off
i will i will i will i'll have to eat it
tomorrow because i can't eat like after
six o'clock because of acid reflux i
don't know if any of my other pregnant
women this is the newest symptom acid
reflux that wakes me up in the middle of
the night choking on my acid burning my
throat
burning my throat
it is so scary to jilt out of bed not
like gasping for air
every single night multiple times a
night
that is so scary so painful and also
like scary i'm like am i choking
right okay so it happened to me one time
i never had acid reflux before i just i
don't even remember
like i just
shot out of bed choking
and then i shot out of bed
shot like literally and ben i was so
freaked out he took me to city md the
next morning and they were like you have
pneumonia i'm like what oh my god
i'm like i can't have pneumonia i'm
supposed to go to atlantic city and like
i remember being in atlantic city being
like is this irresponsible do i have
pneumonia but i just had acid reflux you
probably just ate too close to bed too
much
too close a girl boss too close to the
sun you really did do you have any
additional thoughts on elizabeth holmes
after the stirring debate i do because
and i said before i gave my piece like i
don't know much about the situation i've
never watched a documentary this is just
what i've gathered from social media and
then the opinion i i based that off of
um and i did get a lot of messages i
guess she was defrauding like those rich
people but also taking advantage of
patients and of course i don't condone
any of that but it was a joke and it was
a really funny one so i am gonna stick
with it so i just want everyone to know
when you hear me like making these
elizabeth homes as a hero jokes
know that it's a joke and it's so funny
so you can laugh i completely agree that
it's so funny i was laughing all day
yesterday and also reading the comments
were making me like me too because you
know when you think about it like when
you think about this girl boss you know
boss babe culture that we live in like
elizabeth holmes is kind of like our
face of it yeah our queen exactly
i kind of look like elizabeth holmes
you do
except she would be wearing a black this
is actually a bump suit which is um like
a pregnancy like head like neck to toe
suit oh all the way down to your legs
all the way down to my legs it's so
comfortable i just got them and i wish i
got them sooner because now i'm not
going anywhere so today was like the
first day i was dressing up and i was
like i have to put it on how do you pee
there's a zipper down the back got it
yeah so i'm just like really really
honestly it might be more comfortable
than wearing pajamas because it's like
holding everything together
in a non-threatening way
in a non like nauseating way yeah i
actually think you would really like
i think i want to wear them when i'm not
pregnant is that weird
no okay i'll let you guys know how it
goes anyways happy for kanye that he's
finding love and you know dining well
and enjoying the theater i can't believe
you've never been to cover but carbon
that is so weird oh right i know isn't
that like so embarrassing like even when
we went to vegas we didn't go no we went
to um went to cidels
yeah yeah
but no i've never been
to carbon and that's just like something
maybe that'll be like your first mom's
night out how about that i'll tell you
yeah um before we move on to the next
toy i gotta let you guys know about some
lower back pain i've been having and the
whole medics massager that has changed
the game so yes my back has been really
bothering me recently and i think i'm
just like getting older and that's what
happens as from what i've heard so i
have this fabulous product that you've
got to check out from homedics they've
got a whole line of massage products to
uh from a massage gun a built-in hot and
cold technology to a massage cushion
that lets you lie down or sit up
depending on your therapeutic needs and
they also have a three in one foot
massager with vibration so powerful
it'll loosen the muscles in your legs
and back
so
basically they have a product they have
massagers that address pain points from
head to toe um we have tried a lot of
the products my favorite one is the
massage cushion that lets you lie down
or sit up depending on what you're
trying to
massage um and they're just great things
that honestly every person over 25
should have in their house because you
know things aren't getting easier for us
as we get older and i do suffer like i
throw out my back a lot it's just good
to have that type of um product in your
home
they also have an eight plus from the
better business bureau so they're a
brand you can rely on and you can join
the millions of customers who trust the
home medics family to take care of
theirs
so whether you're dealing with chronic
pain or just looking to help your
muscles from a workout we've got good
news right now if you go to homedics.com
toast and use the promo code toast
you'll receive a free portable phone
sanitizer when you buy a hundred dollars
of more or more in massage products so
it's a sixty dollar value at hometics h
o m e d i c s
dot com slash toast use the promo code
toast for the free portable phone
sanitizer with a 100 massager purchase
check it out
your lower back will will thank us
homedics came into my life at just the
perfect time of you know lower back pain
foot pain and i've been thoroughly
enjoying it it's one of those pregnancy
products that are just getting me
through so pregnant or not pregnant it's
it's great stuff look forward to using
it
forever
next up jason derulo is cuffed after
attacking a man who called him usher
the savage the singer jason derulo let
his wild side come out in the lobby of a
vegas casino tuesday when he allegedly
attacked two men one of whom shouted
quote [ __ ] you [ __ ] at him and called
him usher according to video of the
incident the video seems to show the
singer pouncing on the hecklers at the
aria resorting casino while coming off
an escalator and passing a group of
onlookers who had taken out their phones
to capture their brush with the musician
on video in a clip posted by tmz someone
in the crowd can be heard shouting why
did you slap him dog and then the
separate voice yells hey usher [ __ ] you
[ __ ] in an apparent reference to
another recording artist uh sure unclear
whether he actually thought it was usher
or that was you know a wise crack
but um
this is like a really crazy story and i
also like don't know how being called
usher is like so insulting to someone i
don't think i saw the video i don't
think that
he was you know attacking them because
they called him usher i just think that
was like a part of the video that people
i think found funny
um because i don't think he mistook him
for usher i think it was like a dig but
the thing is i saw the video and these
two guys were like totally like
troublemaking menaces like looking for a
fight like really um provoking him and
like like being rude
but i mean come on jason derulo like you
are so famous what you're getting in
fights with with fans or whatever you
want to call them in hotel lobbies like
we are you're supposed to be above this
like yeah they were taunting him for
sure like baiting him but he shouldn't
have given in like
you're a superstar what are you doing
yeah yeah i agree that's really annoying
though but i agree that he you know
hopefully what should have just moved on
right because now it's like this big
thing
no one he looks just like a loser
yeah and like the headlines are all
saying it's because he was called usher
and as you said that's probably
irrelevant to why he felt the way he
felt and now it's just got me thinking
of the level of self-confidence that
jason derulo has because like when
you're you know super successful and
you've all these people around you who
are like always lifting you up like you
should be above like you shouldn't be
able to be so easily taunted by three
morons in the aria with an iphone
yeah i agree i feel like things were
going really well for jason derulo and
now i feel like
he's maybe going through a rough patch
you know he's getting divorced from like
his wife who he was you know they've had
just like the best thing going and then
all of a sudden it's over and let's talk
about that perhaps it wasn't his wife
oh
just girlfriend and they had just had a
baby three maybe five months into them
announcing that they were no longer
together but then they seem to like kind
of be back together on tick tock it's
very unclear we never got like a clear
message as to
what's going on but i always thought
there was a lot of weirdness around that
breakup like you're breaking up with
this woman you've been with for a while
who had a baby who's three months old
with you right and they seem so happy
and so you don't just like so i just i
feel like maybe he's going through some
stuff and that's an interesting point
like hopefully he works it out within
himself hopefully because behavior like
this is just not no bueno no and i love
jason darrell and i just i want him to
be thriving and i feel like for a long
time he was so hopefully he can come
back to that positive place
if i could just quickly do a chart of
jason darullo's success because it's so
bizarre to me like obviously when he was
only a musician he had like a real peak
jason derulo
and then he kind of became like a has
been really quickly but then tick tock
really
um reinvigorated his career out of this
whole new level and it shot him back up
music wise but then also just like
celebrity wise but now it's kind of
having that adverse effect like he does
all these like stupid skits that are
like like vine comedy i'm like what are
you doing
it's tough out there yeah it's like he
stayed too long at a party
and now it's sad
yeah
yeah
i agree then maybe maybe that's what
he's feeling he's trying to find his
next party right and now he's like at
the place where some of his like you
know drama with his girlfriend and
mother of his child was like playing out
on tick tock and she was like responding
to men it's just like tacky and you're
like you should be above that jason
dorillo yeah but it's also like he is
having this resurgence because of
tick-tock right and so
these things are happening also because
of tick-tock it's you know you can't
have one without the other it's a
double-edged sword you can't have the
tic tac success without the tick-tock
drama
so true
are you ready for our next story was
just some delicious food news
oh i thought you'd never ask
kfc will now sell plant-based fried
chicken nationwide oh my god we've gotta
go we've got a mukbang
starting on january 10th kfc fans can
taste the chicken list beyond fried
chicken oh my god this just sounds like
heaven i mean the pictures look amazing
i'm sure you know
they're editorialized of course the
chickens are photoshopped yeah
but still looks and sounds delicious
vegetarians will finally get to enjoy
kfc's finger licking good kentucky fried
chicken in plant-based form beginning on
monday customers can try kfc's new
beyond fried chicken developed by beyond
meat exclusively for kfc at
participating restaurants across the us
so i'm sure like the participating
restaurants are not anywhere near us
okay even though so that's what i was
gonna say even though new york city and
i'm sure like you know based on
demographics this is just speculative
but i would imagine like there's more
vegetarians
in new york city you know where people
like oklahoma probably plant-based
dieters
yeah like cities than
elsewhere
no i think that's a fair assumption we
always go through this like we announced
on the show there's a new thing making
sense mcput when it comes to actually
getting your ass up going to a
restaurant and ordering it like it's
impossible so
i exist and i think that these big pr
announcements should also roll out
locations cities zip codes because we're
constantly getting our hopes up for you
and the mcplant and we've never really
been satiated no we've never been
satiated i've never encountered a
mcplant in my life
and you know i'm i'm constantly seeking
it out
i mean i'm always at mcdonald's and i'm
always with you and we're always asking
if there's a mc plant and they're like
excuse me and they never is but that's
why you gotta give props to burger king
because there's always a beyond burger
the burger beyond whopper franchise
impossible
impossible
they are leading the space in
plant-based options not only did they
walk the walk they talk the talk there
is actual products at all of their
you know uh locations no matter if it's
on like a shitty side of the road or in
a strip mall like they got you covered
at burger king yeah and that was kind of
the takeaway from our mukbang it's like
is burger king completely underrated
yes yeah but it's just with this one
menu item and it's really like looking
at this kfc chicken is so exciting and
it's like wow i could go to kfc and get
a whole meal and it's like that's how
other people feel all the time about
like everything what a fun feeling
privilege privilege truly literally kfc
privilege
well i'm gonna keep an eye out on like
ubereats and stuff and see if you know
these items ever pop up and i could
order oh yeah uber eats like i just feel
like it takes so long for
it takes so long for the man the ceo who
releases this announcement down the
pyramid to the actual restaurant into
our hands it's like a year later that
you'll actually get what you heard about
right but this is like we're in the
process january 10th is the rollout five
days
start the campaign you have to look into
i'm sure there's a place you could find
the select locations that will be
providing this yeah there should be a
blog that's like
um
plant-based
fast finder food fine plant-based fast
food finder that's good
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
i am
oh [ __ ]
i didn't get mine
like i have it but it's not in my room
that's okay i'll take it so sorry
what's it time for
oh that's right
the final story
[Applause]
[Music]
miley cyrus what the [ __ ] did you
do that's a magic number
gorgeous feels good
feels good our fifth and final story is
a little casting news
chris evans is in talks which one's that
evans um
captain america
yes and
knives out
yeah yeah yeah
is in set is in talks to play iconic
actor gene kelly in upcoming film
gene kelly you know from
singing in the rain
oh yeah yeah yeah
so chris could be stepping into the
legendary actors dancing shoes he's in
talks to play the iconic star in a so
far untitled film people can confirm
gene kelly died in 1996 at the age of 83
based on an original idea for from the
captain america's star so i hope he gets
the part if this was his idea right the
film tells the story of a 12 year old
boy who works on the mgm lot and
develops an imaginary friendship with
the singing and the reign actor while
working on his latest movie
so is chris evans playing the 12 year
old boy or
he would be playing the actor who makes
an imaginary friend
well
he's oh he's the actor or is he jean
kelly i'm sorry it's
okay
okay
it's not an imaginary friend it's a
fictional friendship like it didn't
happen in real life
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
so i feel like this is the sort of thing
that could totally so just confirming
chris evans is playing gene gene yes got
it okay
in a you know a half true story
see i
like i don't see this i don't see chris
evans being like a dancing you know
actor from the 50s
but this just might be the role that
like changes how we see him because i
know him as like captain america you
know big sexy man with his leotard but
maybe there's more to chris evans than
his leotard honestly i see this and i
think this would be the role that like
changes him from being so commercial to
more
niche academic history serious artistic
but also like gene kelly sing in the
rain like that's fun [ __ ] that's dancing
singing like it's it's not like morose
so i think this could be the perfect
thing for him and it sounds like him
does he sing sing and dance
i i think he must have some some chops
if he's putting himself up for it that's
true
you know i'm sure he can dance i don't
know yeah i guess it's like la la land
with ryan gosling i wouldn't have
thought that he was like a singer or a
dancer but he did he did that he did do
it
do you think he did it not well i don't
know i mean i don't like the movie and
by all accounts i should so i'm tempted
to blame him and emma
yeah one of my takeaways from that movie
was like it was good but like imagine
how good it would have been with like
two trained singers and dancers oh
yeah i agree like there's something that
i mean julian huff so many people love
the movie and to them it's a perfect
formula but for me there's something
that was amiss i've never i watched it
more than once me too i completely agree
and like i'm about to say something
crazy but i actually like hate the movie
yeah no like if you wanted to watch it
like i would probably go home
no or like i would be on my phone the
whole time and it's a long movie so
that's a lot of screen time but there is
that day like da da da da like the music
is good yeah because it's pasik and paul
pasek and paul do it again like by all
accounts this should have been you know
a steeny classic and it should have been
oscar movie of the year but it wasn't it
should have been
like greatest showman level of
of love from me of entertainment caliber
of like you know
caliber
yeah agreed anyways but this movie does
sound good and i hope for chris evans
that he gets the part that he wrote for
himself because like that would be weird
also the last time we spoke about chris
evans on the show was like the pretty
believable rumor that he and selena
gomez were dating and absolutely nothing
ever came from that
and that's that's when it gets tough to
do this job when you invest in something
and you hear something that really
tickles your fancy and it's just a big
fat nothing burger
yeah and then it's like seemingly was
like pulled out from midair like there
was no proof ever it makes you wonder
what other nothing burgers have you
eaten
that you didn't even know
a lot a lot five seasons of doing this
show we've eaten a lot of nothing
burgers
and not that many beyond burgers no not
enough and no mc plants none
well those were the fast five stories i
feel as though you needed to know them
and now we need to recap vanderpump
rules because i caught up last night and
i do have a lot of thoughts i was
feeling obviously it's not the best show
on television but if you like do that
you know i have one thing to say i know
you i know i just like to give a little
teaser of one sure sure
even though it's not the best show on
television it was eliciting some strong
reactions from me
agreed
okay echo your sentiment 100 so i'm also
going to talk about emily in paris in
the tv recap segment which is brought to
you by zotique skin care do you look in
the mirror every morning to see dark
marks spots and unsightly acne scars
from when you were younger a lot of us
do we've tried other products that leave
our skin dry peeling and they even
create fine lines and wrinkles before
our thirties well let me introduce you
to zoutique skin care artfully crafted
for all skin types and using uses
scientifically powered ingredients to
deliver the complete result that your
body deserves
so t clarity the new deep correcting
serum provides the benefits of lactic
acid with zero irritation or drying to
your face and now you can get the purest
vitamin c effectively delivered to the
deepest layers of the skin that need it
most this hydrating deep correcting
serum promises glowing skin that is
smooth as silk free from dark marks and
a visible reduction of acne scars so
i've been using it now for like three
months so the zotique products
especially the hyaluronic acid ones are
really really premium and you're right
like you don't see some of that
destructive behavior other skin care
companies have like making your skin
really dry or red
the products just really blend nicely
into your face
and right now you can get 15 off zoty
clarity at z o t i q u e skin care dot
com enter codetoast15 that's toast15 at
checkout and you'll get the 15 off again
zotique skin care z-o-t-i-q-u-e
skincare.com codetoast15
your order is shipped free to your door
with guaranteed results or get a hundred
percent of your money back get zotik at
zotique skincare z-o-t-i-q-u-e
skincare.com codetoast15
for your 15
off
thank you now i feel like we can
properly recap
okay so this episode was kind of crazy
because now it at least to the viewer as
it pertains to brock and sheena's
engagement it appears as though
he tried to get randall and lala like
footed with the bill that didn't work
out tried to then in a crunch time pay
for it himself cheap out couldn't afford
it
and is now piggybacking off of james and
raquel's gorgeous wedding engagement
weekend in is it palm springs i don't
know where it is but
santa seems like
that seems like his plan now and
honestly like i know i do kind of want
to see it happen
because it'll be so crazy but ariana and
tom really should have urged him against
it like that is so mean to raquel
so wrong this man is a [ __ ]
cheapskate like it was
so infuriating to watch and at first i
was like
when lala was like he expected us to pay
for his wedding and his engagement i was
like no he didn't like yeah whatever but
by the way literally brock doesn't even
really know lala and randall that well
and as of recently was like in turmoil
with them so explain to me why out of
all the friends he has in life he went
to lala and randall first for help
sorry i think i think i'm gonna explain
his his thinking like he saw that tom
sandoval paid for and put on raquel's
engagement so he was like okay this is a
group of friends that does stuff like
this for each other so if i want to put
on a surprise wedding like i'm going to
go to the friend who's going to put on
the best wedding for me lala and randall
and they honestly it seems like they
feel bad about like the foot that they
got off to with him and like lala really
wants to do right by sheena so like she
wanted to help as much as possible
obviously not pay for it so at first
when she said he expected her to pay for
it i was like there's no way he expected
that but then to see what he did
afterwards
at every s turn i'm like oh no he really
really did the idea
that he would piggyback on their
engagement weekend where like they chose
this place i'm sure they're playing
paying for the venue they're paying for
all the activities it does and i'm sure
they're getting discounts whatever but
like
they planned it
and he wants to piggyback in secret when
like you are filming a television show
so there are no secrets the idea that
this could even be a secret is null and
void from the jump we all like even if
they were able to keep it hush-hush
until it aired like it still would never
ever have been a secret
is so wrong and just like [ __ ] mooch
and now it's like
it's making me look at everything even
though there was like moochie vibes the
whole time but you know what like
sometimes you gotta hustle and that's a
fine line between a mooch and a hustler
so true you know and sometimes you do
have to ask your friends with hundreds
of thousands of followers if they'll
post for free like and sometimes you're
in the right to do that if that's a
friend and you need a a helping hand
like that's how they can support you but
now like now seeing how he is going
about this i'm just like everything he's
done until this point is so muchy also
him and sheena have been together for
about two years and all of a sudden they
need to have like this shotgun wedding
immediately what the [ __ ] is that like i
understand it being both of their second
wedding so they're not having this like
big hollywood to do that i totally
understand but how do we go from that to
like literal secret shotgun wedding
i have no idea like there are so many
places in la oc or on the up and down
california that would put on a wedding
for them whether they wanted small or
big and
they could you know be within their
budget because there are places that
would work with them that would give
them a place for free
but he like one doesn't even want to do
that work and two like doesn't want to
pay for anything and if i were sheena
like this would make me feel so small
and watching like i don't want to be the
girl who got married on someone else's
engagement
party
terrible it's terrible jackie like it's
painful to watch and then like now
you're seeing everything through this
lens of like really getting a good idea
of who brock is and like why he makes a
lot of the decisions that he makes and
then seeing him put a ring on six credit
cards that he clearly can't afford um
but like trying to keep up with what
china wants it's just it's all very
alarming it's all coming off so toxic
like when they had that little like
hiccup in their interview like she was
basically saying she gave more than ten
thousand dollars for him to start
homebody and in return wanted seven
percent and he was just going back and
forth on what the amount of money she
gave him was and he got like so angry
it's like i'm just
i'm not sensing a good future and i'm
really proud of sheena for getting a
prenup yeah yeah no i agree also the
morganite ring thing which we've
experienced on um
selling sunset which it's like in
general i get whatever ring is gonna
make you happy it doesn't have to be the
biggest thing it doesn't have to be
diamonds but the idea of spending twenty
five thousand dollars on morgan night
when that is the cost of a
really nice diamond ring
like that's just i mean i don't know
that much about morganite but that just
doesn't sound like a sound investment
and also like if you are trying to
tighten
up
she's he's trying to give sheena the
biggest possible ring
period right and 12 carats like who
needs 12 carrots and you're not even
going to nobody learn anything
it's so it boggles my mind and the fact
that every time like the cost of the
wedding comes up and he's like well now
i'm paying child support i gotta i can't
pay for everything and it's like okay
he's child support once he's child
support once and now like can't afford
anything else for himself but can afford
a 25 000
not diamond ring
so stupid
and i'm i know that next week they tell
sheena about the plan to do shotgun
wedding
and i'm very curious if she's gonna have
the self-awareness to put a stop to it
because i i don't really follow like i
don't i don't know if we're supposed to
know what ended up happening with them
because
are they married right now i don't know
i don't want to know i like it's like
watching a scripted tv show like i have
no idea where this is going um
so i don't know what she's gonna say
yeah i don't know either i do feel like
she's gonna be swept off her feet like
she's
it's like if all that stuff hadn't
happened with shay and the and her
literally having to fork over half of
her
that was crazy bank account she wouldn't
get a prenup with brock but it's like
fool me once for you know she couldn't
do that again but like she really is so
trusting and just like
she falls in love with people and just
like
has blinders on and i'm not saying that
she needs to like break up with brock or
anything but like i really would hope
that she would be like we're not getting
married on someone else's engagement
weekend that they planned it's not even
about money like it's about the fact
that like we are going there for them
they took time like
they took weeks to plan this like
there's imitations and everything and
like just to make it about you it's like
the tackiest thing you can do
yeah and you know
sheena's a lot of things but she's not a
mooch and i just i hope that she puts a
stop to it because then it's like
brock's moochiness is rubbing off on her
and then they are the mooches
yeah no it's not
it's not a becoming trait he was really
really bothering me and i felt like for
the past few episodes like i couldn't
get a full read on him in so many ways
i'm like he's so great for sheena like
i'm so happy for her he seems like you
know even with all of his drama like he
seems like a nice guy who's really like
in love with her and maybe this is it
but i just feel like we're now seeing
like who he really is and he's a user
and i think that that is just an awful
quality
and so obviously like he was the reason
he's a phony he's a phony with a 12
carat ring
that is
not
like who needs a 12 car ring
literally nobody and you know
he really took up most of like the
the space in my mind for the episode but
there was one other thing that happened
that actually well there's two things
one three things sorry
like i can't watch anything about
schwartz and sandy's because it's so
painful like knowing that all these
loans they took out all the money
they're like you're you're you took out
a a personal business loan or whatever
and you're giving that money to tom
sandoval i can't think of two dumber
things first of all no like tom sandoval
is going to lead tom schwartz into
financial ruin and that is not what i
want to see when i turn on my television
and like i just pray to god that they
like in real life they don't end up
opening this restaurant but like they
are like breaking ground like they are
moving forward and it's just very sad to
see it's very sad to see i agree the
second thing is that i also don't think
it's the right time for anyone to be
opening up a sandwich shop let alone a
sandwich shop called something about her
or something with her whatever it was
called and like i was so on katie's team
with the schwartz and sandy's things but
now if my options are a bar called
shorts and sandies or a sandwich shop
called something about mary or whatever
it was called i'm going with shorts and
sandies
oh that's interesting while i didn't
love their original pitch idea i do have
faith that they will you know
mold it and it will become something
else but i do like the idea in general
and i think it's also a much more
conservative idea than trying to enter
the like nightlife space bar yeah bar
like that huge cavernous place that they
have that they're gonna have to fill
every single night as opposed to like
opening a sandwich shop and like you
know
having
more
likes just something a little bit
smaller but i also i don't know she
really like touched me when she was just
like getting really emotional about
having something for herself and i feel
like that's something that a lot of
people can relate to but i also feel
like
when you're a reality star and even a
celebrity sometimes like you know
there's so many perks and i'm not gonna
like i'm not gonna start playing a tiny
violin for these people because they you
know get paid so much money to do these
shows but like there really is like a
lack of purpose and like you wake up in
the morning and you don't have something
to do and you don't have somewhere to go
and like that is not you know good for
that's not like life you're supposed to
have like drive and things to do and
places to go people to see and like you
know people who are counting on you and
like i feel like the life of a reality
star especially like on vanderpump rules
it's very
empty
when they're not filming probably it's
probably better when they are filming
but i feel like there is a lot of
emptiness and i feel like her just even
acknowledging that aside from like
wanting to have a baby and not having
one yet like i i appreciate that she can
acknowledge that this lifestyle is not
what she wants for herself
yes i completely agree i thought it was
very like open and brave of her i just i
worry about the financials of everyone
on the show but i do think katie was 100
right in the way she explained how like
she's been in business with best friends
before and it was awful and you really
shouldn't ever go into business with
like your best friends but her and
ariana are like
they're friends not by choice like by
circumstance and i wouldn't say their
best friends like they know like where
the line is and they both like have the
same amount of like love in their hearts
for each other i actually think the two
of them together as a team make a lot of
sense
i agree their friendship is probably
more predicated on professional
circumstances just from doing this show
than it is
on emotions and i feel like they both
get that and sometimes yeah that's
exactly who you should go into business
with not people where there's so much
emotion riding on it and whose business
sense you don't really know anything
about
and then the one thing that i wanted to
talk about was something that really
[ __ ] bothered me because tom sandoval
went over to lala's house to get his
makeup done and you know lala's so great
like she can actually make me like
anyone so they're sitting there like
having a good conversation i'm like you
know what maybe tom sandoval isn't that
bad and then literally five seconds
later he turns around and like not only
does he pretty much lie about what
lala had said um about james and raquel
he's like gassing james up like trying
to get him mad at la la and it's like
what are you doing like why can't you
just have a nice thing and like have it
let it be a nice moment she wasn't
talking [ __ ] like you guys were just
friends kind of recapping like what's
going on in the group he was like she
kind of spun it to me james that like
you're controlling i'm like what are you
doing he's so [ __ ] two-faced
yeah no i think that lala has his number
and i think like him coming and wearing
her makeup like was a solid
for like a nice favor that he did for
her so she was gonna like you know
be nice to him in her house but i i
can't imagine she can stand him
also do you ever do have you thought now
that like lala and james are both single
yes of course
do you think that they would make a good
couple
no i agree
like i know it's hard for people to like
really understand how like guys and
girls are like can be friends but i
actually think they are real true
friends
yeah and i don't think that they should
date though they always do have just
like the cutest moments and he's always
like making her laugh
but i guess it doesn't mean like you
have to marry that person no but i hear
you like a hundred percent okay okay
cool um and then i just really want to
quickly talk about emily in paris um i
won't spoil anything obviously um but it
was so bad and towards the end like
there was there was some serious
low-budget acting happening and one
scene in particular like
really got to me like when her roommate
mindy was in the park
like going through some drama with her
band mates because like her bandmates
found out like oh no her daddy's rich
like it was so stupid and they're acting
and it was giving community theater and
it was so embarrassing like i was
actually like if somebody had walked in
on me if some is bruno marking he's mad
he was upset to hear about the community
theater if someone whom i respected
walked into my room and saw me
associated with that show like i would
have been embarrassed so i i kind of
like needed to evaluate like is this
worth ruining my reputation over
watching this show i don't think so
okay that's those are some strong words
i'm sorry i said what i said and i said
it well
okay i'm still gonna
dip my toe in but i will only go as so
far as i can because i just like i can't
be watching or consuming content that is
hurting me
yeah that's like embarrassing and
bringing shame to your family
agreed and that's why bruno was barking
he's like auntie you cannot be watching
these things
you know what i want once again are on
the same page i want to watch bruno in
paris
me too bruno and theo crew
head to uru
so good so good
so that is our show that is the greatest
show ever created
and we want to thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show every monday
through friday you can find us on you no
let me just i was trying to be creative
but i'm not going to stray hold on
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday and youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i heart radio cast box all
the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us morning toast and leave
a five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are and if you
made it to the end of this episode thank
you so much for being a true iconic
toaster who listens to the valuable
words that come out of our mouths and if
you made it to the end of the episode
let us know why don't you go drop a
comment on our most recent instagram
of the triangle to
honor and
respect the fact that the triangle has
made its return to the morning toast
love you guys we'll see you tomorrow
happy hump day bye